i want to make one clarification on my
video of on super or actually say
supernovae because that's the plural for
supernova is that i said this supernova
occurred a thousand years ago that's
actually not precisely right the
supernova was first observed a thousand
years ago or the light from that first
explosion was observed by astronomers we
believe a thousand years ago but we have
to be very clear here because the crab
nebula and at its core is roughly 6500
light years away even this light even
this image we see right here is that
nebula as it was 6500 years ago and so
the supernova itself if we think about
when it actually occurred it actually
must have occurred about 7 500 years ago
so it must have occurred about 7 500
years ago
years ago and that first light from that
first explosion from that first
energetic event
reached us
about a thousand years ago so re so it
took 6 500 years to get to us and
reached us a thousand years ago so first
first light
1000 years ago 1 000 years ago i just
wanted to make that clear it might have
been obvious to some of y'all but always
important to think about it when i said
a thousand years ago i really should
have said it was first observed the
explosion was observed a thousand years
ago but since it's so far the actual
event must have occurred 7 500 years ago